A huge, huge fan.
Oh, is that okay?
Can I fan out a little bit?
Yeah. Why not?
Yeah. You're an Emmy Award winne
You've been on the big screen.
You've been on the small screen.
And now you're the streaming sta
holding it down on HBO, Netflix.
What is that like?
It's way
more enjoyable
if you never expected
the moment to happen.
So I just you know,
I think it's the surprise of it
all that makes it so fun just be
I just
I truly believe if I had expecte
all to happen,
it never would have happened.
I think. I don't know. I don't k
Who knows?
You know,
sometimes I think
I don't even want to analyze it
I don't want to jinx it.
It's just this weird,
you know, lucky moment.
What do you mean, weird lucky mo
You mean to have success at,
you know, at the ripe young age
we won't say, but yes.
Yes.
Don't say
because Hollywood is such a
it's like youth.
I mean, I think one of the reaso
I think people have had such a
maybe a
big response
on both sort of both shows that
came out and stuff like that is
I think a lot of people,
you know, even
especially I think Cobain
has something to do with this.
Like I think a lot of people
want to feel like they have a ch
at something
that maybe they thought
it was a missed chance.
And I think I'm a good example o
And I am deeply deeply insecure.
I know a lot of rich white
people.
So let's have fun. Okay.
When you think about
about White Lotus, right?
Because this
the success that happened during
and everybody was watching,
I watched it, actually binge wat
when I had covered you.
And so I was watching it
as I had covered, and I was like
I want to be in a way with them.
And then I said,
these are such awful people.
I don't know,
but I'd still like to be in that
Yeah, we were so a lot of us wer
I mean, not
some of us not intentionally awf
but yeah, we're spoiled. Spoiled
Why do you think it was such a s
As you think
it was because of COVID
or obviously it's
because it's a great series.
I think Mike White has this.
You know,
he's very tapped into who people
and how to tell a story.
I think his stuff is very real.
And then we had a lot of,
you know, strong feelings
for Murray Bartlett's character,
you know, sympathize
being in and, you know, look,
I was a cocktail waitress
right up until my 30 and my
right before I got stiff.
Was Mom you trying to seduce me?
Yes, ma'am, I am.
And the big screen, at least wha
I came to know you as a sex symb
as simple as mom.
Like people were like they were
it was mom is hot.
I'm just really glad the White B
didn't
cast a supermodel for that role,
because I think they wanted
a woman
who might be in the neighborhood
and not look, you know,
I mean, like, not as super.
I'm really glad that went with s
kind of normal.
If I am, you know,
if I can pull that off.
Like,
I thought it was like a normal w
that, like, you know, just
some kid would maybe have a crus
Let's go to the watcher now.
Yeah.
The other
your other success,
that's also a hearing at the sam
Excuse me.
Did indentured servants build th
Do you know
what
I mean?
How would I know?
It's scary.
Yeah, it's creepy.
I think people love it
when it's a true story.
And it really did happen as some
Creepy people are always more
interesting than monsters.
You know what I mean?
Like, what if it's any sort of r
or anything?
It's
nothing is creepier than a creep
I think the folks in streaming n
have more of an influence on the
and are even in some ways, bigge
than people on the screen.
On the big screen, in the box of
I should say, they go to movie t
I feel like maybe
the people that are watching,
you know, streaming these shows
and so I guess
aren't as in love with perfectio
as the previous audience.
I make a million wrong moves in
and I think maybe
the streaming people like that.
I think you're right about that.
That's part of the success
because it's more relatable.
No one's ever said I'm
right about anything. You're rig
You are an LGBTQ icon.
The gays love you.
How did that how do you.
Are you aware of that?
That's just to
my friends, was since I was a ki
you know what I mean?
Like, it was
that's always sort of been my gr
And,
you know,
you don't mean you
just like when you're a kid,
you just go to
who you're attracted to or you
you have
stuff in common
with another champion for the co
as Leslie Jordan.
And you worked with him on the C
It may be a rom com cliche,
but I want my ex-wife
and my boyfriend to like each ot
That's my little man.
What was that experience like?
What was he like?
He's so deserved all the
the glory he got
when he came on Instagram
and was saying just very simple
You can't get that many people o
unless you're just
he was just a really pure, kind
So you're on a high right now.
You're on a high right now.
What's next?
What do you think?
Bigger and better stuff.
I don't know. Like I say, like
I however,
however long this
ride is, I'm going to ride it.
I don't know if I'll ever have a
like this again.
So I'm I'm just enjoying it till